la mayor parte de lo que hemos visto
hasta ahora ha sido de átomos aislados
hemos hablado del número de electrones
protones neutrones y la configuración
electrónica de los átomos pero los
átomos no sólo operan de manera aislada
si ese fuera el caso el universo entero
incluidos nosotros sería un montón de
átomos la deriva lo que empieza a ser
interesante es como los átomos
interactúan entre sí una de las formas
más interesantes en las que pueden
interactuar es cuando se unen unos a
otros de alguna forma y lo que
estudiaremos en este vídeo es justamente
la manera en la que los átomos se unen
otra forma de pensar lo es que
estudiaremos como los átomos forman
enlaces como veremos hay varios tipos de
enlaces es un espectro de enlaces
pero empecemos con el que considero que
es el tipo de enlace más extremo y para
entenderlo
vamos a traer la tabla periódica de los
elementos así que digamos que estamos
trabajando con un elemento del grupo 1
digamos no sé el sodio lo que es
interesante de estos elementos del grupo
1 es que tienen un electrón de valencia
si queremos observar el electrón de
valencia del sodio podemos dibujarlo
usando la estructura de puntos de lewis
a veces se le conoce como diagrama de
lewis como el sodio neutro tiene un
electrón de valencia podemos dibujar su
electrón de valencia justo así ahora
vayamos al otro extremo de la tabla
periódica pensemos en el cloro el cloro
es un halógeno y los halógenos se tienen
7 electrones de valencia así que el
cloro tiene
2 3 4 5 6 7 electrones de valencia
podemos imaginar que al cloro le
encantaría tener un electrón más para
poder completar su capa más externa y ya
hemos estudiado en otros vídeos que
estos átomos estos elementos en la parte
superior derecha de la tabla periódica
que no son los gases nobles sino en
especial la parte superior de los
halógenos y elementos como el oxígeno y
el nitrógeno son muy electro negativos
les encanta atraer electrones
acapararlos entonces qué crees que
pasará cuando pones dos átomos juntos
bueno este átomo quiere perder su
electrón y el cloro quiere ganar un
electrón o por lo tanto el cloro tal vez
tomen este electrón del sodio en una
reacción química tenemos billones de
estos átomos que rebotan por allí y
varias cosas pasan pero por simplicidad
imaginemos que solo tenemos estos dos
así que tenemos este cloro que está
listo para atrapar un electrón de este
sodio entonces qué pasará bueno el sodio
quedará cargado positivamente ya que
perderá un electrón mientras que el
cloro ganará un electrón o por lo que se
convertirá en un unión de cloro un año
no es un guión negativo y un ion es un
átomo o una molécula con carga entonces
nos quedaremos con un camión de sodio es
decir un guión positivo y este es una
unión de cloro tiene los electrones de
valencia que tenía antes y puedes ver
que ganó uno del sodio y ahora tiene una
carga negativa ahora bien que sabemos de
los iones positivos y negativos
qué carga supuesta se atraen ley de
colom a estos dos átomos se van a atraer
entre sí otra forma de verlo es que se
quedarán unidos y otra forma de verlo es
que estarán formando un enlace así que
formarán el compuesto cloruro de sodio y
observa aquí el compuesto completo tiene
una carga neutra tiene una carga además
1 del sodio y de menos 1 del cloro pero
juntos tenemos una carga neutra porque
estos dos están unidos y puedes adivinar
cómo se llama este tipo de enlace entre
iones se llama enlace iónico